we're just outside the russian-held city
of donetsk
the front in this war stretches more
than 300 miles
well we're just approaching the small
town of piske and it's right on the
front line the russian soldiers are a
kilometer or two ahead of us
we're with a unit holding one tiny part
of a long line
dotted all along it are towns and
villages like piskey
not that there's much left of this place
anymore though
this is artillery
yes yes
this was home to two of the few
civilians who have held out here
two days ago it was hit
one woman was injured but she survived
nearby this is the very limit of the
ukrainian resistance the unit's platoon
commander is dennis gordeev first
position to enemy
about
there about
800 meters
in trenches from a different century
they have the simplest of weapons and a
few have the most sophisticated too so
this is a british weapon yeah it's
british weapon
an anti-tank missile
each one of these shoulder-fired
missiles can take out a russian tank
the mines too they hope will stop a
russian advance here but they can't stop
the artillery
no no no no no
it's normally oh look that all time
like i said all time now it's normally
here in the donbass the lines were drawn
many years ago since the russians took
crimea in 2014 this has been contested
but they're digging deeper this time
it's my life it's life my children my
kids my
mother
my wife and my people because i'm
ukrainian
enemy won't
destroy my country yeah not only cities
not killing people destroyed my nation
the russians have regrouped on the land
beyond all their forces are now
concentrated in this part of the country
but this new offensive won't be quick
the assessment here is that these are
just preliminary strikes for a much
larger assault in the weeks ahead
some of the soldiers have been here
fighting and sleeping for the last year
tired and short of weapons but on their
own land up against an invader they
believe they will win
mark stone sky news in pesky ukraine